so last semester my grandfather passed
away and I was responsible for
explaining to my two sons how to how a
funeral works okay and so I'm a
professor right I pride myself on being
able to explain things clearly so I went
to tell my five-year-old son sort of
what's going on during the funeral I
told them your papa's body is up in that
wooden box up there we're gonna
celebrate him right now we're gonna go
to the cemetery and then we're going to
bury him you know and you know I'm I'm a
professor I thought I nailed it
okay except my son's was showing this
looking look of concern in his eyes
and he looked at me he's like what about
his head okay so my plea for this
semester is please let me know when I
forgotten the part about the head okay
you know you guys are listening to me I
might have forgotten something that to
me seems kind of obvious but that for
you it would help to know to understand
the material okay so today we're gonna
start with cells and so here you can see
this is one of my favorite movies this
is a neutrophil sill cell here that's
migrating you can see it chasing after
this smaller cell which is a bacterial
cell and around this neutrophil what
you're seeing here are these red blood
cells which aren't doing very much of
anything okay so the point I'm making
with this video is that cells have a
huge amount of diversity so cells have
diversity diversity as you can see from
the video there's a diversity in size
there's diversity in shape and also
diversity and behavior
okay so we're gonna unpack this a little
bit and I just want to start by kind of
just pointing out that until now in this
semester we've dealt mainly with very
small things such as atoms small
molecules lipids and proteins and the
size of these structures they're on the
nanometer scale
okay now cells are unit up in size and
cell cells span several orders of
magnitude in size so bacterial cells are
on the small side they're on the one
micron to ten micron size so you can see
that here there's most bacterias about
one micron to ten micron but our cells
span from tens of microns to hundreds of
microns and even larger than that
because the the human egg is on the
order of a millimeter in size this is
not a human egg but this is a frog egg
you can see often the egg cells are the
biggest of all cells the biggest cell is
an ostrich egg okay it's about 15
centimeters I believe okay so cells span
a huge wide range of sizes I'm going to
start with the simplest which is a
bacterial cell and what I want to point
out about this cell is its simplicity
okay so here you can see this is a
electron micrograph of a bacterial cell
here and this is a cartoon just
illustrating some of the key features
you have a plasma membrane and a cell
wall the cell wall here is in sort of
the periplasmic space is in green and
this encapsulates the cytoplasm and the
only other real structure you can see in
this case is this nucleoid structure in
the middle and what the nucleoid is is
is just the back of the chromosome of
the bacterium okay and I want to point
out that later on in the course
professor Imperiali is going to come
back and tell you about how about
antibiotics and how bacteria can develop
antibiotic
resistance which is of critical
importance for biology and medicine so
our cells are more complicated than this
and that's because if you look at this
yam here you can see that eukaryotic
cells and we are eukaryotes have
membrane-bound compartments there's a
nucleus here that houses our nuclear DNA
and also there's a series of membrane
compartment compartments that span the
cytoplasm okay now our cells even in a
single organism such as us our cells
have incredible diversity and
specialization so there's diversity
within a single organism
there is specialization so as we develop
from a single cell our cells acquire
properties that allow them to carry out
specific functions in our bodies okay
and so an extreme example of this is
shown up here these are pictures or
drawings of neurons from rimoni qahal
and you can see how this looks nothing
like the cartoon picture of a cell I
just showed you these cells have highly
dendritic sort of a raise of protrusions
and these cells have evolved such that
they are very good at sort of
transmitting information in the body
right an extreme example the nerve is a
sciatic nerve which extends from the
base of your spinal cord all the way
down into your foot so it's about a
meter long okay that's that's an extreme
specialization for a cell okay so these
cells are specialized but what's
important to note is that in within a
single organism the genomic DNA of a
cell is more or less the same okay so
genomic DNA
is the same with some exceptions some of
which we'll get to in the course the
genomic DNA is the same what's different
is the genes that are being expressed in
these cells and the proteins at the end
code that give these cells different
functions okay so what's different and
what allow cells to acquire these
different functionalities is a different
gene expression okay so that's the
overview now I want to talk about
compartments and if we go back to this
cartoon that I showed you from your I
just wanted to point out that right now
at MIT in the brode there's a project
that's ongoing to really define all the
cell types that are present in humans
and this is known as the human cell
Atlas and I just want you to take a
minute to think about if you wanted to
define different cell types what would
you look at to classify these cell types
anyone have an idea yes what's your name
Rachel
what's that you could look at function
that might be a little subjective and
how to interpret is there some what
defines the function of the cell
[Music]
mm-hmm but is there something I guess
within that cell that would define what
its function is yeah what's your name
semantics semantics semantics all right
yeah gene expression right what genes
are these cells expressing right so what
they're doing is they're isolating
single cells from tissues and then
they're looking at gene expression so
which which type of molecule here would
be the molecule you'd want to look at if
you wanted genic want to look at gene
expression so not miles Malik
MRNA exactly Malika is exactly right so
you look at the MRNA right because if
there's mrna mrna that means that gee
that gene was expressed and is possibly
encoding the translation of a protein
okay so that's what they're doing
they're isolating single cells and doing
a massive single-cell RNA seek project
and that's helping to identify new cell
types in the human body okay coming back
to compartments so I showed you this
picture you can see there are lots of
membrane-bound compartments in the cell
you can see the lines in this cartoon
represent lipid bilayers and so these
are compartments that are completely
encapsulated by a lipid bilayer okay and
I'm going to remind you of something
that Professor Imperiali told you about
already and the reason I'm saying it
again is because it is so freakin
important okay so if we consider a plat
a lipid bilayer where the circles are
the polar head groups of the lipids and
the squiggly lines are the fatty acid
chains I'm not going to draw all the
fatty acid chains so this is a lipid
bilayer and these head groups are they
hydrophilic or hydrophobic yes what's
your name
Steven they're hydrophilic they like
water right the water is on sort of the
different phases here these are
hydrophilic okay how about this central
region here
yes named Ori hydrophobic good right
that's excellent
okay so these are hydrophobic
hydrophobic so what that means is you
have this hydrophobic layer that is
surrounding each of these compartments
and that's going to serve as a barrier
such that water and things dissolved in
water cannot
passed through this barrier unless
something allows it to okay so each of
these compartments that are
membrane-bound have a properties in the
lumen
that's an interior of the compartment
this can be different from that of the
cytoplasm and the cell the interior of
the cytoplasm is going to be different
from that of the extracellular space so
let me just give you some examples of
how things are different inside and
outside the cell and also inside and
outside these compartments so if we
consider the EXO plasm versus the
cytoplasm we can consider the
concentration of various ions now I want
to get the concentrations right let's
consider sodium is a monovalent cation
potassium and calcium okay I'm just
going to use these as illustrations so
sodium is concentrated outside the cell
about 150 millimolar and is less
concentrated in the cytoplasm okay so
there's a huge difference in sodium
between the outside and the inside of
the cell okay
potassium now you might think potassium
would be a lot like sodium it's a
monovalent cation it's a similar size
but it actually shows the flip
distribution so it's for millimolar in
the exo plasm and a hundred forty
millimolar in the cytoplasm okay so
there appears to be some selectivity
here or if the cell is allowing is
concentrating certain things inside the
cytoplasm and it's excluding others okay
so there's selectivity even between
closely related atoms here
okay calcium is to millimolar in the exo
plasm and around 10 to the negative
fifth millimole
in the cytoplasm okay so because there
are these huge gradients in the
concentration of these ions leads you to
expect that this is a non equilibrium
state because if it were equilibrium
these ions would go in and out and
they'd equilibrate such that the same
concentration would be on the inside as
the outside okay and so there's
selectivity and also it's a there's non
equilibrium which suggests that energy
is required to maintain this asymmetry I
want to point out is not just the
concentrations of various molecules that
are different between the inside and
outside but the plasma membrane can also
have a voltage across it okay and so
this is EXO plasm this is cytoplasm and
this membrane can hold a voltage and
this is going to become incredibly
important when we talk about neurons
because cells neurons use changes in
this voltage to transmit signals across
their length and also to transmit
signals at the synapse okay and we'll
talk about that later in the course so
this is known as membrane potential this
voltage difference
okay I also again want to point out this
this endomembrane system in here where
the gray regions here are sort of
compartments that will communicate with
each other and so there's this whole
internal structure of endomembrane
system which is compartmentalized from
the cytoplasm okay and so now I want to
talk about how do things get in and out
of this structure okay so I think this
we're up to three getting in and out
okay so cells and this is very important
in cell communication right which for
cells to communicate cells have to send
things like signals to other cells and
also cells can take in stuff and sort of
receive things from other cells so how
is it that this happens well if we
consider the plasma membrane of the cell
right this is a lipid bilayer PM i--
bre v8 plasma membrane PM so that's a
lipid bilayer and let's say that there's
some type of sort of molecule that's on
the outside of the cell so in this case
this would be EXO plasm out here this
would be inside in the cytoplasm here
let's say this cell wanted to sort of
take up this pink structure into the
cell okay how would it do that well this
pink structure be is this hydrophilic
cannot pass through the lipid bilayer
hey so this cell has to use another
strategy to take this up into the cell
see I'll use a little blue here so let's
say the region of the membrane right
here is in blue then what can happen is
this blue structure can invaginate and
it can take up this pink molecule okay
so the plasma membrane can invaginate
the plasma membrane can imaginate and if
it has this pink molecule then if
there's a sijin event here you've now
gone from having your pink molecule on
the outside of the cell to having the
pink molecule in this vesicle or
circular structure structure on the
inside of the cell okay so here now we
have this we have our vesicle and blue
and now the cell has picked up this pink
molecule such like this okay so when
this process of sort of taking material
from the outside and sort of bringing it
into the inside of the cell is known as
endocytosis which is the process of
taking something from the outside and
bringing it in the cell this is also a
way that viruses can get in your cells
which is a more nefarious way that this
the system is used all right I need a
volunteer yes
Oh ori come on down
don't worry so be simple I just need you
to put pressure on my head right here
right so you see the tassel make sure
they can see the tassel you see this
tassel this tassel is that pink molecule
is right now on the on the outside right
but I'm gonna endocytosed it by going
like that right and I also got a hand
that's great okay so you see it's just
that's basically endocytosis right I
just endocytosed my tassel okay all
right
you can go up we're all set yeah I can
do the next one okay so the opposite of
this process let me get another color
here you can also have vesicles that are
on the inside that then fuse with the
plasma membrane and release their
contents to the exterior and this is
called exocytosis
so exocytosis is something that's
starting out inside one of these
vesicles and then goes out okay so this
is not exactly reversible because there
are different protein machineries that
mediate either endocytosis or exocytosis
so now I'm gonna exocytosed my tassel
there we go
so I just exocytosed it and now my
molecule is again on facing the outside
world okay so this is a way for cells to
sort of take in things and also to
secrete molecules like signaling
molecules into the extracellular space
okay so now we're moving on and now
we're going to talk about compartments
within compartments so our on four
compartments
within compartments and you're gonna see
how this relates to endocytosis in just
a minute so compartments within
compartments okay so the example I'm
going to use here is an organelle that
is present in us in animal cells which
is the mitochondria and you all know
that the mitochondria is the powerhouse
of the cell whenever I say mitochondria
is the powerhouse of the cells I have to
do ten push-ups because it's so cliche I
mean my five-year-old knows the
mitochondria is the powerhouse of the
cell it's a gross oversimplification ok
the mitochondria are way more
interesting than that and I'll show you
in just a minute
alright I'll draw mitochondria the same
mitochondria that my kids draw me okay
so here's a mitochondria I'm drawing
first the outer membrane so there's an
outer membrane to the mitochondria and
this organelle also has an inner
membrane so this is the inner membrane
the inside here is called the matrix
I'll draw draw some DNA molecules there
so this is actually this is known as the
mitochondrial DNA which I'll mention in
just a minute okay so this is the
mitochondria where could such an
organelle come from evolutionarily
speaking and you know one problem that
eukaryotic cells have is they cannot
make mitochondria de novo okay the way
that mitochondria is passed on is it's
replicated during cell division and it's
passed on from one cell to the next okay
and you guys all got your mitochondrial
DNA and your mitochondria at least
initially from your mother okay so this
is not an organelle that can be
synthesized de novo and the fact that
this is the case has led to a theory
known as the endosymbiotic theory or
hypothesis which basically states that
there was an ancestral eukaryotic cell
and the way that organelles such as
mitochondria and plastids were derived
is from engulfing bacterial cells that
were either capable of oxidative
phosphorylation in the case of
mitochondria or were capable of
photosynthesis in the Cape in the case
of chloroplasts okay and so this
engulfment is much like this endo siddik
process that I just talked to you is not
really endocytosis because these
bacteria are much better than an end
acidic vesicle so it's more of like a
macro sort of the macro pinocytosis or
something like that okay okay so
something you may have seen in the news
lately so some of the evidence for this
endosymbiont theory is that mitochondria
and
have their own DNA okay so these
organelles have retained DNA and this
DNA the the genes in the DNA encode for
proteins to function in the mitochondria
it also includes ribosomal RNAs and
transfer RNAs that are required for
protein synthesis within the
mitochondria okay but a lot of the genes
that are required for a functioning
organism have now been exported to our
nuclear DNA and those genes are made and
proteins are produced and then they're
imported into the mitochondria but the
mitochondria has rain' retained a number
of genes and it's encoded in the
mitochondrial DNA another reason to
think that this could be from a
symbiotic relationship
this ancient between eukaryotic and
prokaryotic cells is that these
organelles divide by fission okay
similar to how bacteria divide so they
divide by fission okay so I'll show you
a real mitochondria in a mitochondria
undergoing fission in just a minute I
just want to point out that in the news
recently there have been talk there's
been talk of three parent babies and I
just want to point out explain to you
what that is okay so eggs that are I
shouldn't say embryos but eggs that are
given that have the nuclear DNA from two
parents can then be given by Nicandro
DNA from another parent so these three
parents babies are essentially babies
that have nuclear DNA from two parents
but mitochondrial DNA from a third
parent okay so here's just an article in
the news scientist reporting that this
is imminent and now it's been done okay
now why would you might want to do that
anyone know why someone would want to do
this
yes yeah so Stephen right Stephens
exactly right right there are diseases
that are so associated with faulty
mitochondrial DNA okay and if you're a
mother and you have the mutations that
cause this disease though this would be
a way for you to have a child without
passing on the disease to your child
okay and so this is something that is
still controversial but that's why the
people are exploring the opportunity for
making these so-called three parent
babies okay again I have a pet peeve
with text book pictures of mitochondria
right here's your textbook picture
everything's labeled nicely this is what
mitochondria look like in real life
mitochondria
like the endoplasmic reticulum actually
formed these tubular networks that
essentially span the entire cell okay so
it's convenient for us to depict
mitochondria like this in text book but
mitochondria are way more interesting
than that they're dynamic organelles and
I also want to make a point we kind of
talked about these organelles like they
behave as these separate entities but in
fact they interact with each other and
there's lots of interesting biology
behind that so I'm gonna show you one
movie that's from work done by Ghia
volts and this Friedmann person is the
first author she just gave a talk here
at MIT and showed some beautiful movies
I focus on this movie here the ER is
labeled in green and the mitochondria is
in red and what you see is there's this
mitochondria tube you'll and it's
crossed by the ER right here okay now
focus on this and when the movie plays
you're gonna see that the mitochondria
undergoes fission right at these points
where the ER and the mitochondria
intersect okay so that illustrates and
now they've mechanistically dissected
what sort of makes the mitochondria
undergo fission at these crossing sites
but it really illustrates the real sort
of
complexity and dynamics that are present
in a cell which you might not be getting
from your book
oh I did want to mention that so there's
a there's a chapter in your book I think
it's key concept 5.3 where you can read
about all the organelles okay you should
read that in know roughly what the
organelles do okay I mean I could
lecture about that but it would just be
so boring that I can't do it I'd have to
do a ton of push-ups so we have to sort
of choose what we lecture about so I
would just suggest you read that part in
the textbook if you have questions come
talk to me and just be familiar with
what your organelles are doing yes Ori
is 5.3 it's key concept 5.3 he's
probably listed on the assignments right
yeah
yeah all right I have one last part
which is to prepare you for Friday's
lecture okay and Friday's lecture we're
gonna start talking about genetics and
before we talk about genetics we're
going to talk about something that is
we're gonna lay the groundwork
essentially for genetics by talking
about how cells divide so I think one of
the most miraculous things that cells do
is that they can undergo this trick
where they replicate themselves and
split into two daughter cells okay and
you're seeing that here there are
chromosomes in the middle here they're
gonna line up along the metaphase plate
and now they're gonna get pulled to
separate sides
you're gonna wiggle back and forth first
then in just a minute they're gonna get
segregated know they'll go eventually
there they go okay so you see and then
the cell is gonna pinch at the equator
and divide in two okay
so now I'm at this last part the
cytoskeleton because the cytoskeleton is
the answer to part of how the cells
divide okay
and before I prevent present the
cytoskeleton I just want to briefly
mention chromosomes and what they look
like so the chromosomes right are your
nuclear DNA they're linear pieces of DNA
as opposed to the mitochondria which has
circular DNA and again the fact that
mitochondria have circular DNA is
analogous with sort of bacterials
chromosomes where bacteria have circular
DNA okay but our chromosomes are linear
pieces of DNA and you guys have probably
all seen chromosome spreads that look
like this so this would be a chrome a
chromosome that's replicated there are
two copies one and two so this is a
replicated and condensed chromosome
right initially chromosomes are just
like bowls of spaghetti everything
mixed together but during mitosis the
chromosomes condense and then they sort
of resolve from each other such that you
can see the arms of the chromosome and
you can see where the chromosomes are
coupled to each other at this structure
here which is known as the centromere
okay and at this centromere a protein
complex assembles I'll just draw it like
this
this protein complex is called the
kinetochore the kinetochore is a complex
of hundreds of proteins that assemble
into this large platform that sits on
the centromere and the kinetochore is
able to attach to the cell's
cytoskeleton specifically microtubules
so this attaches to microtubules and I
will tell you what microtubules are
right now so microtubules are a
component of the cell's cytoskeleton so
the cell cytoskeleton is a network of
filamentous rods that are present in the
cell and the term cytoskeleton kind of
makes it sound boring I think because it
makes it sound static but the
cytoskeleton is anything but static it's
actually a dynamic machine in the cell
and these machines that are assembled
from these fibers are able to generate
force okay so these microtubules and the
cytoskeleton they generate force okay
you can think of them as motors or
machines so they are machines that
generate force and I'll just illustrate
this with a couple of videos and slides
so again this is not a stable structure
but very dynamic so this is going to be
a movie where in green here microtubules
are labeled
and the red labels the nucleus and these
cells in this fly embryo are going to
undergo cycles of Seldon or nuclear
division and so you're gonna see the
microtubules assemble disassemble
assemble disassemble so you see how
dynamic this process is the cell is able
to assemble this force generating
apparatus which is known as the mitotic
spindle each and every cell division
okay so this structure or machine is
critical to physically segregate the
chromosomes to opposite poles of the
cell okay so now I'm going to tell you
about the microtubules themselves so
microtubules as the name implies are
sort of tube like polymers okay so these
microtubules are biopolymers which means
that cells are expressing sort of genes
that encode for proteins that form a
subunit that can then self assemble into
a larger rod like structure okay and you
can see one of these rod like structures
here they essentially look like straws
there are about 25 nanometers in
diameter and I'm going to show you this
video showing you microtubules both
disassembling it first and then
assembling so that's a disassembling
microtubule but they also assemble to
form these longer rods like structures
okay so these bio polymers are dynamic
and they both assemble but also
disassembled and both the assembly and
the disassembly can generate force okay
microtubules can push if they pull them
or eyes into something they push it
right just like you're kind of like
poking someone with your finger okay now
they also disassembled and when they
shrink and disassemble they can actually
pull okay and I'll show you an
of that right here so this is an example
that's reconstituted meaning they're
just purified proteins here there's no
cell okay and what this is is a bead and
you see that dark the dark stripe here
is a microtubule you can see it growing
there's the end right there that
microtubule is going to grow it's going
to grow out to about here and then at
the end of the movie it's going to stop
growing and the microtubule is going to
shrink back and you're gonna see that
when the microtubule shrinks back is
going to actually pull this large bead
and pull it towards the left side of the
slide here it goes there deep
polymerizes and pulls you see it so
these microtubules can generate a
pulling force that's strong enough to
pull this glass bead and also it's
strong enough to pull an entire
chromosome okay it's actually much
stronger it generates much more force
than it requires to pull a chromosome so
that seems like there's some robustness
in the system so that it's generating a
pull that's much stronger than needed to
actually drag a chromosome through
viscous media so during mitosis the way
this system is set up is there's a
what's known as a bipolar spindle I'll
just write down that we'll come back to
it and Friday's lecture there's a
bipolar spindle and the bipolar spindle
is made up of a number of microtubules
so here you can see there are two poles
here and here and in the middle along
the sort of equator of the cell the
chromosomes will line up there just two
chromosomes here and you can see how
microtubules reach out from the pole and
attach to both sides of that chromosome
and you can imagine that when these
microtubules are told to shrink and
disassemble if they're able to remain
attached to that kinetochore which they
are when they shrink they're gonna pull
the two
copies of the chromosome away from each
other okay and so this is the basic
machinery that allows for chromosomes to
be segregated in cells okay that's it
for today any questions all right
terrific good luck on your exam on
Wednesday it's in here
you